- Alright.
So we are presenting
on "What Drugs Could Treat COVID-19?"
- So, hi, everyone.
As our wonderful host
mentioned, I'm Lindsey.
I'm a grad student at
Rockefeller University
and I'm originally from Connecticut,
which is that star
that's a little bit
to the left in red.
- Yeah, and I'm Emily Costa.
I am studying at Weill Cornell
and I'm originally from Massachusetts.
So that slightly shifted star
(Lindsey chuckles)
in the right.
But yeah, it works.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
(chuckles)
Alright.
So I'm actually
when obviously there's
not a pandemic happening,
I'm super interested in
understanding how behavior works
and specifically how the
brain is able to generate
sometimes super cool and
sometimes not so cool behaviors.
And so I do this by studying ants
in Daniel Kronauer's lab at Rockefeller.
And as many of you might know,
ants are actually a really great system
to study social behavior
because they live in colonies
and they communicate with each other
and they have division of labor.
So some ants are specialized nurses
and take care of the young
and some specialize in
foraging and look for food
and they all kind of work together
to keep the colony alive and happy.
And my research specifically is focused
on understanding how ants which have,
I mean, most of you have
probably seen an ant before.
They have very small heads
and very small brains
to go inside those heads,
but they're still capable
of these pretty extraordinary
social behaviors.
And so actually on the left here,
I have a picture of an ant brain.
And what my research has focused on
is figuring out what brain
pathways are important
for social behavior and
specifically communication
between different ants to
coordinate their behavior.
But I'm not in the lab all the time
and when I'm not in the lab,
I really enjoy spending
time with my family.
You can see them on the bottom left here.
I think some of them might be watching.
But I grew up in Connecticut
and so it's really nice.
I can just hop on the train
and go home and visit them.
And I also really, really love animals,
you can see our family's dog
was in our family portrait.
I have two cats.
You might see them running
around on the cat tree.
I asked them to stay as calm as possible,
but they don't really speak human.
So we'll see.
I also love baking.
I think it's a really nice
way of sort of being creative
and experimenting.
It's especially nice at times like now
where I can't be in the lab.
And finally I really love
talking about science
and thinking about new ways
to communicate science.
So I love volunteering with RockEDU.
I also have done other
outreach sorts of things
and specifically one that
was really fun was working
with artists with intellectual
developmental disabilities
to create bio art.
- Hi, so I'm Emily or M for short,
and I'm currently doing
my PhD or graduate school.
I'm currently in graduate
school at Weill Cornell,
but I actually do my thesis research
just down the street
over at Sloan Kettering
in Charles Rudin's lab.
And there I studied a type of lung cancer
called small cell lung cancer.
And in particular,
I'm trying to understand
how to make immunotherapy
work better for patients
with small cell lung cancer.
So immunotherapy is basically
a type of cancer therapy
that engages our body's immune defenses
to attack cancer cells.
So the kind of immunotherapy
that I'm in particular study
is called immune checkpoint blockade.
And the way it works,
is basically there's this
interaction that happens
between tumor cells and immune cells,
involving two proteins,
PD-L1 which is on the tumor cell
and PD1 which is on the immune cell.
And normally these two proteins interact
actually as a function of
preventing auto-immunity,
which is when our immune cells
accidentally attack our
bodies' normal healthy cells.
The tumor cells actually
use this mechanism
as a way to hide themselves
from the immune system,
which would otherwise actually notice
that they're really abnormal
compared to our healthy cells
because they have so many mutations.
So basically we figured out as a therapy
that if you block this
interaction using antibodies,
which can either bind to PD-L1 or PD1
and keep them from binding to each other,
then you can actually
have the immune cells,
specifically T cells,
notice the cancer cells.
So they can no longer hide
from the immune system
and then they can attack
and kill those cancer cells
and start healing patients' tumors.
So it's a pretty cool technique
and as I mentioned,
my work is focused on
using this kind of therapy,
and making it more effective in patients
with small cell lung cancer.
So when I'm not in the lab doing science,
you can find me talking about science
pretty much anywhere else.
So I really love
volunteering with RockEDU,
both in their lab experience program
and also at Science Saturday,
which is a program they do every summer.
This was from the last Science Saturday
where myself and a couple
of friends in grad school
ground up a lot of strawberries
and then showed some kids
how to extract DNA from them,
which is a really fun, messy time.
I also talk about trivia
and share science stories on a podcast
called Facts Machine,
that I run with some of my
friends from grad school.
It's funny and punny
and we have a lot of fun doing it.
And I also really enjoy projects
that kind of look at the
intersection of art and science.
So for example,
last year I had the
really cool opportunity
to work in a project scripting
a series of short films
about the history of women in science.
And I also enjoy doing
this kind of photography
called cyanotype
that folks in the 19th century
actually used to use to kind
of catalog botanical specimens,
and sort of like capture images of plants.
Now I do it because it's just
kind of a really pretty
thing to do and a nice hobby
but that history is kind of cool, I think.
(chuckles)
Alright.
So the paper that we're
gonna talk about today
is an example of scientific literature,
but what do we mean by
scientific literature?
So literature as we call
it in the research world
is how scientists basically
write about their research
and then communicate it to each other
in a way that's informative,
expedience and trustworthy.
So as you can imagine,
the first step in generating
scientific literature
is actually doing the research.
So scientists will be in the labs,
running experiments,
collecting data,
and then once they decide
they have research they'd like to share,
then they'll write about it in a paper
and then this paper will go to two places.
It can go to an open source publisher.
A really popular one in life sciences
is called the bioRxiv,
and papers that go open source
are available for anyone
to read immediately,
which is really helpful
when the information that
the authors are sharing,
can be used by other
researchers really quickly.
Like COVID-19 research
it's especially useful to
have open source journals.
But a caveat to this
is that the papers that go
to open source publishers
are not peer reviewed.
Conversely, another
place that papers can go
is to peer reviewed journals.
So you've probably heard of some of these
like Nature, Science,
Cell,
PLOS, PNAS,
there are loads and loads of them.
But here the papers actually
do get peer reviewed
and then once they're
published by the paper,
then they can be read by people
in the scientific and medical community
who will then apply these findings
towards their own research.
So I wanna take a little
bit more time though
to kind of explore the differences
between open source publishing
and peer reviewed journals.
So to kind of talk about peer review
and explain what that actually means.
Basically,
when authors submit a paper to a journal,
the editor of that journal
will then forward that paper
to other experts in the field
that the paper comes from.
And those experts will,
who are also scientists,
will look at the methods
and the data in the paper,
and basically evaluate whether
the experiments were rigorous
or whether more experiments need to happen
in order for the authors
to actually make the claim
that they make in the paper.
So this process can involve
the authors going back,
doing more experiments,
resubmitting to the journal,
maybe getting rejected by the journal,
and then submitting to another one
and starting peer review at that journal.
So although peer reviewed
papers are regarded
with more confidence than open source
because they have this
kind of vetting process
that's built in,
it also takes a lot more time
for papers that undergo peer review
to actually be put out
where people can read them.
Another main difference
between open source publishers
and peer reviewed journals
is the degree of access
that people have to have these papers.
So some journals actually
require that scientists pay them
to publish their papers,
which can then limit where
and whether labs can publish.
And additionally,
some journals also
require that you pay a fee
or have a subscription to
read the papers in them,
which can then as you imagine,
also limit who gets to read those papers.
A lot of journals nowadays
are moving more towards
an open access model
where you can actually
read their stuff for free.
But overall that whole
situation is avoided
with open source publishers.
And one more kind of limitation to access
that plagues scientific
literature in general,
no matter where it goes is jargon.
So scientists like usually
using a lot of jargon
which are basically technical terms
that are kind of difficult to digest
if you're not a specialist
or not in the fields
that the terms come from,
which can make the literature,
you know, difficult to access for people
who are not in the fields.
But it's also why we
do data for the people.
So there are ways to work around it.
(chuckles)
There are also I should say,
various types of scientific literature.
So the paper that I was just describing
and the paper that we're
gonna look at today,
are both examples of original research.
So I mentioned these,
present the research,
and the authors hypotheses,
their methods and their data.
But there are also short
reports and letters
which kind of tell
shorter research stories,
review articles
which kind of summarize
the salient findings
in a single topic or fields,
case studies,
which you see a lot in medical journals.
And those will cover specific instances
of interesting phenomena like a patient
who has unusual symptoms
for a certain disease.
And there are also methods papers
where authors can showcase a new method
or technique that they've developed.
- Alright.
So moving into the paper
that we are going to
be talking about today.
This paper is called
"A SARS-CoV-2 protein interaction map
"reveals targets for drug repurposing"
which is a lot of words.
To break it down a little bit,
in this paper they're going to start
by looking for protein interactions
for the virus SARS-CoV-2,
which we all know is
the novel Corona virus,
which causes COVID-19 disease.
And we'll talk more about
what protein interaction
means exactly.
(phone rings)
And then after that,
they're going to look for drugs
that might be able to be repurposed
or used in a different
way to treat SARS-CoV-2.
And we'll talk a lot more about this.
And this is a super, super exciting paper,
but it's also still very much
the only beginning of research
and there's a ways to go
before drugs like this
or drugs from this paper could
be used to treat patients.
Another cool thing
and one of the reasons I
wanted to talk about this paper
is because of how fast,
can you go back for one second?
- Oh sorry, (laughs)
- It's fine,
you're right.
(laughs)
It's how fast the research has progressed.
So you can see,
or maybe you can't see,
but this is actually,
this is a peer review journal article now.
But when we started talking
about making this presentation
like a week and a half ago,
it was still a preprint.
And one of the reasons why we think
that this has progressed so quickly
is because of how many authors
there are on the paper.
So there are,
can you go to the next slide please?
Thank you.
There are 25 authors,
and they work in over 20 labs
across eight institutions,
which is a wildly big collaboration.
You can see those eight institutions
on the map are the stars
are indicative of them.
And you can see they're
mostly located in the US
but there are also some European labs.
And I think it's just been really cool
to see how the scientific
community has really come together
to try to understand SARS-CoV-2
and how to potentially treat it.
Also really cool about this paper,
is that even though it's just come out,
it's already been highlighted in the news.
And so,
its findings have been
discussed in the New York Times
as well as in the conversation.
So now we're gonna turn things over
and start talking about
the body of the paper.
- Great.
So before we jump in,
we'd actually like to
take a little bit of time
to sort of explore some key terms
that have important roles in the paper,
but that you might be unfamiliar with.
So those terms are
protein-protein interactions,
viral tropism,
phases of drug development
sort of conceptually
and mass spectrometry.
So protein-protein interactions.
So if you think of our cells as factories,
the proteins are the workers.
They're the ones carrying
out all the various functions
that our cells do,
to basically keep our bodies working
and healthy and doing
what they need to do.
And a big part of how proteins
do their particular jobs
is by physically
interacting with each other.
So this works at sort of
like 3-D surfaces of proteins
that are complimentary.
So if you imagine puzzle
pieces sticking together,
that's exactly how this works.
And basically once these
complimentary services
find each other,
they then get held
together by chemical bonds
that form in between them.
So in cells proteins physically interact
to enable certain kinds of jobs.
For example,
some jobs can only take place
if the proteins are together in a complex
that are enabled by these interactions.
Sometimes these interactions
can allow one protein
to make a chemical change to another one
that then affects the activity
of that other protein.
Interactions can also allow
proteins to move around the cell
to different places,
to do specialized jobs in those places
and where did it go?
And protein interactions can assist
or prevent other protein interactions
that might otherwise be possible.
So a very important thing
to know too is that,
lots of drugs work
by blocking disease-related
protein-protein interactions.
And in our paper,
the authors are not only looking
for protein-protein interactions,
but also drugs that can disrupt them.
Some other term that we
wanted to take a look at
was viral tropism.
So viral tropism is the
ability of the virus
to infect a specific host.
And this can happen at
various levels of biology.
For example,
at the cellular level,
we know that HIV can infect macrophages,
which is a kind of immune cell,
but it doesn't infect neurons,
which are cells in our brains.
The flu virus infects our lung tissue,
but not our brain tissue
and even at the whole organism level.
Myxoma is an example of a
virus that infects rabbits
but doesn't infect us humans.
And basically what
determines whether a virus
can infect a specific host
is the presence of certain
things called host factors.
So these are cellular
resources that a virus hijacks
in order to infect and
replicate within its host.
So for SARS-CoV-2,
which we know can affect bats,
monkeys, humans,
and maybe some house pets.
We know that a host
factor that it relies upon
is the ACE2 receptor,
which is a protein that
is expressed in our cells
that SARS-CoV-2 actually
uses to enter our cells
during infection.
So the authors of our paper
are looking for more host factors,
essentially like ACE2,
that SARS-CoV-2 viruses need
by looking for viral human
protein interactions.
Alright.
So the authors of our paper
report that they find drugs
that come from preclinical studies,
clinical trials
and are FDA approved.
So we wanted to take a beat
and kind of break down what each of these
sort of phases of drug
development actually means.
So whenever a lab,
say at a drug
a pharma company,
finds a drug that they
think could be effective
in treating some disease,
the first step for that drug
is to go into preclinical studies.
So at this step,
the drugs are assessed for safety,
in animals
oftentimes mice.
And basically during these studies,
scientists will take measurements
like where the drug goes in the body,
sort of what organs it hangs out in,
how long it stays there,
whether the drug gets broken
down into smaller molecules
that might have different effects.
And once all of this data is collected,
the FDA then reviews it
and decides whether the drug
can go into clinical trials.
So clinical trials are what
you hear about in the news
that are like phase I, II, and III.
All that applies to this
step in the process.
And these trials take place
in patients and healthy volunteers
who receive either the drug or a placebo,
and their purpose is to make sure
that the drug is effective and safe.
And then once the FDA reviews
a whole other bunch of data
from the clinical trials,
they decide whether to
approve or reject the drug.
And if it's approved,
then you can buy it.
It goes in the market,
and it can be prescribed to patients.
So we have a little poll for you guys.
On average,
how long do you think it
takes for a drug to progress
from preclinical studies to FDA approval?
So one end of that flow chart
all the way to the other.
(waits for poll results silently)
Alright.
I think we're starting to level out.
I'm gonna close the poll in
like maybe 10 seconds or so.
Okay.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Alright.
So actually,
oh, this is interesting.
Okay.
So three to five years.
I like the optimism.
It's actually 10 to 12 years.
(chuckles)
So this actually kind of
makes our point pretty well
and that that's not an
insignificant amount of time.
But that's also why this
idea of repurposing drugs.
Oh, sorry.
Okay, maybe now you can see it.
Hold on.
Okay.
I guess we got it.
But that's why the idea of
repurposing drugs is so appealing
because if, you know, if you
have like a brand new drug
that's still to undergo
preclinical studies,
all the clinical trials and everything,
that can take 10 to 12 years.
But if say,
if you have a drug that's
already FDA approved,
even though it would have to be reapproved
to be used in a different disease
than the one that it was
originally approved for,
because we already have some
data from preclinical studies,
we have an idea of how
safe it is in people
and what doses are appropriate,
that process from starting
to getting it approved
is a lot faster than it would
be if the drug was brand new.
So that's why we're
trying to look for drugs
that we can repurpose for COVID,
so we can get them into the clinic
and to our patients more quickly.
- Alright.
So this last vocab word
that we're gonna go over
or vocab concept
is a method that the authors use.
So in this paper,
the authors are trying to
identify the human proteins
that interact with viral proteins
as we've mentioned before.
But the scientists have to figure out
how do they go from having
this unknown protein,
how do they identify it?
And so the tool that
they use to identify it,
click please,
is a tool known as mass spectrometry
or a mass spec for short
because spectrometry is like
kind of a mouthful to say.
And mass spec is a tool
that scientists can use
to identify proteins as
well as other molecules.
And in this paper it
is used for the authors
to be able to figure out
what human proteins interact
with viral proteins.
Next slide.
So going into a little
bit more about what,
how mass spectrometry works.
Spectrometry is a big word as I mentioned,
hard to say.
But it really describes a
method of studying a spectrum
like in this case mass.
Other types of spectrometry
can look at things like color
or fluorescence.
And a mass spectrometry works
by measuring how much
mass there is an object
depending on it's charge.
So it basically is used to calculate
the mass to charge
ratio for each molecule.
So for-
- Right.
(whisphering)
- Sorry.
(chuckles)
So we have some videos
kind of to illustrate this
'cause I know I'm not
gonna like act it out.
That would be weird.
So to...
(chuckles)
The first video is to show
the first step of mass spec,
which is ionization.
So as you can see here,
a mass spectrometer starts
by breaking up a molecule
in this case of protein,
into smaller bits called ions.
And so now all of these smaller circles
or spheres have broken up.
They have to be sorted.
And so these ions or in
the video little circles
go through an electromagnet
which separates them
on the basis of their mass and charge.
So you can see that in this video,
the little blue balls are traveling faster
and the red ones are traveling slower
because they're bigger.
And then finally,
all of these sorted ions
need to be detected.
And so in this step,
the mass to charge ratio
for each ion is graphed
so that we can see how many ions
of each mass to charge ratio
there are in the sample.
And so the results from
a mass spectrometer
kind of look like this piecemeal graph
where you see how big
each individual ion is,
and then you can put that
information together,
sort of like a puzzle
to identify the protein
that you put in at the beginning.
And so
now that we kind of have a basis
of the concepts in this paper,
the two questions that the
authors are trying to ask are
first,
"What human proteins interact
"with the SARS-CoV-2 viral proteins?"
And second,
"Are there drugs against
these human proteins
"that can be repurposed
to treat COVID-19?"
And how are they going to do this?
They use a type of scientific reasoning
that is known as experimental evaluation.
There's lots of different ways
that scientific knowledge can be created,
lots of different approaches for that.
These authors use a series
of controlled experiments
to understand what viral
and human proteins interact
and what drugs might
be potentially helpful
in disrupting those interactions.
And so to actually
perform these experiments,
the authors began,
oh sorry, next slide.
Thank you.
(chuckles)
To perform these experiments,
the authors began by
identifying human proteins
that interact with viral proteins.
So they looked into virus' genome
or genetic material.
And some of these viral
proteins are already known.
And then the others were predicted
based off of what we
know about Corona viruses
and DNA translation in general.
And so,
okay.
And so obviously no one really wants
to get those virus proteins
put into their bodies,
to see what proteins the virus
interacts with in humans.
And so a way that scientists
can still study human cells
is to use something called a cell line.
And so cell lines are cells
that are originally
taken from an organism,
in this case humans,
that are treated with a
bunch of different things
so they can grow indefinitely in the lab,
generally in some kind of
plastic plate or something.
And so most cell lines
have been kept in labs
for a really long time.
So there are some caveats
because the cells aren't exactly,
they don't have all the same properties
as a cell in your body would have,
but they are kind of the best we have
because we're not gonna go around
putting viral proteins into people.
And so in this case,
the authors just use a
human kidney cell line
and they express a single
viral protein at a time.
And so again,
this isn't exactly like what would happen
during a viral infection.
Normally viruses don't
only infect your cells
with one protein at a time,
but this helps the authors
to identify the specific interactions
between a single viral protein
and the human proteins.
And so once all these human
cells were expressing,
or they made the viral protein,
they burst open the human cells
and they took out all of the proteins.
And they did this in a way
so that all of the proteins
could still be interacting
with each other.
So they maintained all those
human protein-viral protein interactions.
And then from this protein
soup that they made,
they pulled out the viral proteins
and everything that was attached to them.
And so from there,
they have the viral protein
connected with the human protein
and they can use mass spectrometry,
which I talked about earlier,
to identify the human proteins.
And finally they put all
of this data together
into these really pretty graphs
that Emily's going to talk
about in much more detail.
But these maps show the
protein-protein interruptions.
- Alright.
So in total of the 26 SARS-CoV-2 proteins,
the authors express in these human cells,
they find 332 human proteins
that interact with them.
And then of those 332 human proteins,
66 were druggable,
which means that we have,
we know of drugs that can bind to them.
So then they looked at all
those drugs that emerged
and you can see they come
from those various phases
of drug development that we
talked about a little while ago,
and they picked 47 of those drugs
to move into Viral Infectivity Assays.
So basically these are
experiments that look at the drugs
and see if they can,
if they reduce the ability of SARS-CoV-2
to infect cells in any way,
which we'd want to see them do,
if we thought they could be
effective in COVID-19 patients.
So to kind of break down
a little bit further,
what that data look like.
So these are two of those interaction maps
that Lindsey mentioned.
As you can see there's a
lot of information here
and there are actually
26 of these in the paper,
one for each viral protein.
So overall,
this paper generated,
you know, these authors I should say,
generated a ton of data.
But just to kind of break down
what we're actually looking at,
so we chose sort of two viral proteins,
or interaction maps as examples
of the data.
One of the viral proteins is ORF9c,
which is a protein the
authors predicted to exist
based on looking at the SARS-CoV-2 genome.
And the other one is NSP6,
which we know is involved in replicating
the SARS-CoV-2 genome.
So each of these viral proteins
are here as the red diamonds
and then kind of at the periphery,
in gray we can see the human proteins
that don't have known
drugs that bind to them,
at least yet.
And in yellow,
are the proteins that do have drugs
that we know can bind to them.
Also pretty cool are these spokes
that connect the human
proteins to the viral protein.
So these based on their
shading and thickness,
actually give information about
the statistical confidence
that the authors calculated
between each of these interactions.
So if you look down here
this MIST Score for example,
is a statistical calculation
between each interaction.
And then,
I think the coolest part of these at least
are these sort of blue
clouds that you see,
kind of like in these clusters
of different human proteins.
So these indicate that the
proteins in the cluster
all share the same biological process
and those are written here in bold.
So for example,
these three proteins
that are in this cloud
are all involved in ion transport,
which is basically just
moving chemical ions
back and forth between
membranes inside of our cells.
And the sort of cool thing
about identifying these
shared biological processes
is that they give us an idea
of not only the proteins that
SARS-CoV-2 interacts with,
but also possibly the general
functions in our cells
that SARS-CoV-2 is hijacking
when it's infecting and
replicating our cells
or in our cells.
So here are the same two interaction maps,
that we looked at before.
Only now the druggable
proteins are highlighted
and the drugs that match them are listed
in these little text boxes.
So you can see the FDA approved drugs
that some of them might
sound a bit familiar.
For example,
Metformin is a drug for type-2 diabetes.
Haloperidol or haldol is
an antipsychotic drug.
Chloroquine an anti-malarial,
is also in a relative
of hydroxychloroquine
that's usually used for patients
with autoimmune disorders
like lupus or rheumatoid arthritis.
And they've also both been
in the news quite a bit
over the past few months for COVID-19.
So one cool thing to note.
Well, one thing to note I should say
with these FDA approved drugs is that
that's great as we heard
a little while ago.
If they are effective,
they can be approved
for COVID-19 much faster
than a drug that was just made brand new.
But this also means,
or I guess this can also mean that
because these drugs were designed
for different purposes originally
and for a different disease,
that they could have effects in our bodies
apart from treating COVID-19,
even if we take them for COVID-19.
But that's the sort of thing
that would be figured out
in clinical trials.
- Alright.
So now that these authors
have found all of these drugs
that could potentially be
useful in treating the virus
by disrupting viral protein-human
protein interactions,
they wanted to test and see if these drugs
actually impacted the ability
of the virus to infect cells.
Again, the caveat is cells aren't people,
they're not organisms.
But this is a common first
step that scientists use
to see if it's worth
spending the resources
to test these drugs in more preclinical
and clinical applications.
And so what they did is
they took cells this time
from a monkey cell line,
and they began treating them
with the drug of interest.
And so
after two hours,
the drugs,
they wanted to ask the question,
if the drug prevents
or decreases the ability of
the virus to infect the cell.
So after two hours,
they infected the drug treated cells
and control cells that
don't have drug treatment
with the virus.
And they kind of let the virus
do its thing for two days
and the ultimate readout
was looking to see
if viral infection was reduced.
And they did this.
So the expectation is
if the drug in fact does
prevent viral infection,
you would see a reduction
of viral infection
or maybe even no viral infection at all.
Whereas if the drug didn't
actually do anything,
which is totally possible,
then viral infection would
still occur normally.
And they measured the level of virus
by looking at the viral proteins
and the levels of viral RNA.
So the authors took those 69
drugs that they identified.
Some of them being FDA approved,
some in clinical trials,
some preclinical,
and they tested 47 of them
in this infectivity assay
to see if the drug prevented
or decreased viral infection.
And so this is an example
of what one of those assays looks like.
This is a drug called PB28.
And just to walk you
through this graph a little.
I know there's a lot going on.
The black line corresponds
with the number of living cells
and this is important
because we don't want the
drug to kill the cells.
We just want it to
prevent viral infection.
And the red line is the
level of viral proteins.
And then on the y-axis we have percent.
So the way you would read this graph is
the black line corresponds
to the percentage of cells that are alive
and the red line corresponds
with the percentage of
viral proteins in the cell.
And then on the x-axis we
have the amount of drug.
And so this is also important.
You might imagine that giving
a lot of drug to the cells,
might lead to the virus
infecting the cells less,
but it also could be more
toxic to the cells and kill,
be more likely to kill them.
And so in this example,
the PB28 drugs seems
to reduce infectivity,
which is awesome.
You can see that by the
decrease in the red line
over the amount of drug.
And so,
but this is just one example.
Not all of those 47 drugs that they tested
did actually reduce infectivity.
And what it would look like
if the drug didn't reduce infectivity
is you would have like a flat red line
just to show that there was no effect.
And so of the drugs that did
seem to reduce infectivity,
there were two major
classes or two like groups.
The first being drugs that bind
the sigma-1 sigma-2 receptor,
and the second being drugs that
prevent making new protein.
So PB28 is actually an example
of that first class of drugs
that bind to the sigma-1 sigma-2 receptor.
And then you would
imagine it kind of like,
I don't know,
hand-wavy kind of makes sense
that drugs that prevent
making new proteins
might also prevent viral infection.
- Alright.
So now that we've looked at
at least some representative
data from the paper,
let's revisit those
questions that we mentioned
at the beginning.
So question one that the
authors set out to ask
in their study is "What
human proteins interact
"with SARS-CoV-2 viral proteins?"
And then question two,
"Are there drugs against
these human proteins
"that could be repurposed for COVID-19?"
So one thing that I think is generally
kind of a good practice to take
whenever you're looking at a study,
is not only see what
the authors found out,
but also what they didn't find out.
You know, every paper that's out there,
will present a lot of data,
but also leave some questions unanswered.
And by kind of consciously
being aware of those,
you cannot only see exactly how far,
the study pushed our knowledge forward,
but also keep an eye out
for the things that it didn't answer.
And then for the research
that's working to answer it,
and follow up.
So for question one,
we can say the authors did
identify human proteins
332 of them,
that SARS-CoV-2 proteins interact with.
And they also showed evidence
that some of these interactions
are important to SARS-CoV-2
viral infectivity.
And actually the authors work
in identifying these human proteins
or SARS-CoV-2 host factors,
actually,
well, not only points us towards drugs
that might be useful in treating COVID-19
because they bind the human proteins,
but they also advance our understanding
about the kinds of cell functions
that SARS-CoV-2 hijacks
when it's in our cells.
And this understanding could also help us
progress towards therapy itself
because although we know that
well, we have reason to think that
drugs that bind these specific proteins
they found might be disruptive,
we can also look for drugs
that disrupt these general functions
that might've not been
captured in this paper.
And we can also test those
and see if they're
therapeutically viable as well.
So for question two,
the authors also identified drugs
that might be able to disrupt
the human viral protein interactions.
And at least in their assays
that Lindsey just showed us
some of these drugs
showed antiviral activity.
But very importantly,
the authors did not find a treatment
that we can start giving to
COVID-19 patients right away.
And that's because the
conditions in their experiments
compared to the conditions
in our human bodies
are so different that
we can't possibly effect
or we can't possibly predict rather
all of the effects that
these drugs would have
in a COVID-19 patient.
So as Lindsey mentioned,
one way in which this is the case
is that all these experiments
happened in cell lines.
And cell lines are
immortalized as we call it,
which means they can grow in a lab,
in some plastic,
in a solution with like sugar,
and just do that indefinitely
and be really happy.
And as you can imagine for
cells to be able to do that,
they have to take on a certain like
some certain behaviors
that are much different
than the cells in our bodies actually do.
So that already makes the
system quite a bit different.
in terms of the experimental system
from what the human body would be like.
Another caveat is that these
cells also don't account
for certain variables that
would be very important
to how patients respond to this therapy.
So when you think about it,
like patients can have all sorts
of different genetic
differences between them
just from one person to another.
They can have other medical conditions,
they can even be on other drugs
to treat those medical conditions.
And all of those would
not be sort of factored in
in the experiments that are
done in these cell lines
and would also have an effect
on how these patients respond
to COVID-19 therapies.
Now this isn't to say that like,
you know, the results in
this study are not useful
or they're unreliable.
To the contrary,
I mean, just based on
those two interactives,
as I said,
there were 26 of those.
So there was a lot of data in this paper,
it came out super fast as like a testament
to this power of this collaboration.
And there's a lot here
that'll be very useful
to other researchers in
the field moving forward.
And it's also not to say too,
with the drugs they found
won't necessarily be
useful to treat COVID-19.
It's just that we can't say that yet
without actually testing
them in clinical trials.
So on that note,
let's take a look,
sort of hypothetically at one of the drugs
that came from this paper
to see what its path might look like
through the clinical trial process.
So there's a lot going on here,
but we'll break it down
and work through it.
So as I mentioned at
the top of the webinar,
when a drug kind of like after
it's developed in the lab
and is like ready to go
into clinical trials,
or at least hopefully,
and it undergoes this
preclinical testing in animals.
And then once the company
runs these preclinical tests,
they gather all that data
and submit it to the FDA
in what's called an Investigational
New Drug application.
So this application has all that data
and it also has description
of the company's plans
for actually running
those clinical trials.
So if the FDA approves this application
then the drug gains
Investigational New Drug status,
which basically just means
that it can be shipped across state lines
to be used in clinical trials.
So then the drug goes
into these phase I,
II and III
at a minimum clinical trials.
And as I mentioned before,
clinical trials take place
in healthy volunteers and
patients with the disease
depending upon the phase.
They'll be treated with
a drug or a placebo
and then their response is to be monitored
over a set period of time.
So clinical trials are designed
to figure out two very
specific things about a drug.
Firstly,
it's efficacy,
which is basically how good the drug is
at treating the disease
that it's supposed to treat,
in terms of alleviating symptoms
or healing the patient depending
on what the drug is for.
And it also measures the
toxicity of the drug,
which means the side effects the drug has
and how severe those side effects are.
So in phase I clinical trials,
which typically lasts
about several months,
the drug is tested in healthy volunteers
and here they're looking for
they're looking at the safety of the drug
and they're also deciding dosing ranges
that will be appropriate
to test in patients
in the next phase.
So once the drug passes phase I,
then it goes into phase II,
and now it's given to patients
with the disease the drug is
actually designed to treat.
So here we have quite
a few more participants
in this phase than in the previous one.
And it also lasts a bit longer,
going from several
months like up to a year.
And then following phase II,
then the drug moves into
phase III clinical trials,
which is still in patients
that have the disease
that the drug is meant to treat,
but now there are way more of them
on the order of hundreds to thousands.
And this phase also
takes quite a bit longer,
usually in the realm of one to four years.
So here as in phase II,
they're still looking
at the drugs efficacy
and its toxicity,
and kind of narrowing down doses
that would be appropriate
to use in the clinic,
once the drug is approved.
But in phase III in particular,
they're also looking for rare side effects
that you'd be less likely to find
when you're testing the
drug in fewer people
as you are in phase II.
So when you see drug
commercials at the very end,
the narrator kind of like whispers
extra side effects at you like a secret.
A lot of those show up in
phase III clinical trials.
So after all the clinical
trial data is gathered
and the trials are done,
then the company packages that up
into what's called a New Drug Application.
They're usually at least
100,000 pages long.
So it's a lot of data
and the FDA reviews that
and then at that point,
either approves or rejects the drug,
at which point it can be marketed
and it can be used to treat patients.
So as I mentioned before,
FDA approved drugs that are
approved for one disease
must be reapproved before they can be used
to treat a different disease.
So now to look at one of
our hypothetical drugs,
PB28,
is the one that Lindsey showed
us some infectivity data for
that looked really good.
But because it's not an approved drug,
it's actually quite far
at the very beginning of the pipeline.
It will be entering here
in the preclinical phase.
And as we learned at the beginning,
that means it could be like 10 to 12 years
between this drug actually
entering the pipeline
and coming out at the other
end and being FDA approved
if it makes it through
the pipeline at all.
By contrast remdesivir,
which is a drug for COVID-19,
possible that's being tested for COVID-19
that's been in the news
quite a bit lately,
was developed as a general antiviral
and it was actually in
phase II clinical trials
back in 2015,
during the Ebola outbreak,
and entered phase III clinical
trials this past February,
in a trial that included
some COVID-19 patients
and it's still in that
phase of trials right now.
And actually there's kind
of a special sort of caveat
with remdesivir.
So as of last week,
because of some preliminary
results that suggest that
it might be shortening
the duration of disease
in certain patients
and the fact that it's just
looking kind of promising,
the FDA granted what's called
Emergency Use Authorization
for remdesivir,
which means that even though
it's not FDA approved yet,
doctors can prescribe it to patients
that have severe symptoms.
So as I mentioned,
like this rule about approving drugs
for a new disease still holds true,
but given the promise of this drug
and the special circumstances
that we're in with COVID-19,
there are some exceptions that can be made
so that way these drugs
that look promising
can get to patients they
can help even sooner.
Alright.
And one last thing that
I want to share here.
So resources that I
found were pretty helpful
and kind of just looking into,
you know, a bunch of
COVID-19 clinical trials
that are going on
and sort of preparing for this data
for the people presentation
I've listed here.
So statnews.com has a
really nice COVID-19,
clinical trial tracker.
It's very reader-friendly,
really up to date
and has like nice descriptions
of what the drugs actually do
and how they actually work.
The FDA of course has great information
about how these clinical
trials are happening.
They also issue frequent press
releases with new findings,
like that Emergency Use
Authorization that I talked about.
And lastly,
if you want to see all of
the COVID-19 trials going on
all over the world,
those are available at ClinicalTrials.gov
and they actually have
them from the WHO database.
That's the coolest list.
- Alright.
So we just wanted to end this
presentation by highlighting
how this was a totally
massive amount of data
and the reason why the authors were able
to generate all these data
is because of the fact
that there were 125 authors
in over 20 labs in eight institutions.
And we also just thought
that it was super nice
that in addition to the fact that
there's already this
massive collaboration,
the authors have also
done a really good job
of making all parts of their research
as accessible and transparent as possible,
including writing in the paper
what their next step plans
are for testing these drugs.
And they're also really willing
to distribute materials to other labs
so that other labs can
participate in help testing.
So we wanted to highlight this by,
one of the quotes from the paper
that just like made us
all feel a little happy
and kind of optimistic in
these very uncertain times.
And this quote says,
"Given the urgent and acute global need
"for SARS-CoV-2 research,
"we will make these resources available
"to the scientific
community upon completion,
"as we have done with this study."
And so we just thought
that was really cool.
And it's nice to know that scientists
they're all collaborating
and working together
to try to figure this out.